[Applause]
today we're combining football with ping
pong let's see which sport wins
me a note Club against the goalkeeper
plus C ready and not at the same time
hit my head and hit my hand
oh wow what a spin nice
I thought that it would be impossible to
return any of those shoes goalkeepers
they save around 40 so
okay let's go
this is pretty intimidating
[Music]
if you're watching this I'm available
for a few million
[Music]
to go here we can take the danger
okay air moves out
nice I thought I would score every
single one but hey milk came out of
nowhere
okay makeup we're six hours in the
world's longest rally is coming nothing
can ruin this not even a flying football
[Music]
you live yeah all right so you
interrupted the table tennis rally quite
easy but let's try and knock the ball
you may have to run away
[Music]
come back so what's the percentage of
you making me shot it's about the same
as the percentage of the viewers that
are subscribed I assume that's pretty
good unfortunately it's only 20 but help
us get to 70 by subscribe
every time I hit you in the head yeah
Lassie gets a point
[Music]
sweaty Palms try my hands try it I can
see it I don't wanna
I thought the crack was from your head I
don't know
let's see who has the best touch or some
balls
[Music]
nice cat the style is free so
do I get three penalties and lastly gets
three smashes and let's see who saves
the most
[Applause]
how did you say that a little mermaid
good goal here at the last moment let's
see what kind of a ping pong goalkeeper
make guys you ready you have three shots
I've never tried saving table tennis
free kicks before
oh
I'm not gonna get that
I win
okay this one I'll call the Shoei
aren't you supposed to hit it in the
shoe that's not possible
it stayed can I get my shoe back don't
leave the rock inside the shoe
Around the Net
[Music]
oh
yes and we'll throw in
[Music]
good corner and I'll finish the goal
[Music]
[Music]
okay which ball sticks so this will take
about two minutes I'm gonna say one
minute
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I'm sorry I apologize
[Music]
remember the game
[Music]
freeze fries it's not gonna take one
minutes even less than a minute so I was
sure it's not gonna even happen
that's how you do it last year you can
put this to use
we are trying to hit 5 million
subscribers so please help us out and
hit subscribe